welcome
to simplifying complex application
development using cloud firestore
my name is min nguyen and i am a product
manager for cloud firestore
we have an exciting session today that
is composed of two major sections
the first section covers why cloud
firestore
and will include key challenges that
firestore sells for
along with a customer testimonial from
khan academy
the second section covers what's new in
cloud firestore
which will provide a sneak peek into
exciting launches and a demo
of an upcoming feature let's get started
okay face it product development is
hard not only do you have to focus on
providing value to your core business
you also have to build complex
applications composed of several
components
applications typically start with a
database
this is followed by apis in front of the
database to handle client queries
of course you will have to keep your
data secure so you will need an ad
and off layer to manage both users and
access
to the apis
users expect applications to be
real-time and collaborative
so you'll have to define a
synchronization protocol
and finally since users have
intermittent network connectivity
you'll have to add support for offline
mode as well
often these components are produced by
several different vendors
and it's up to you to lego break them
together
now if your application takes off you
have to ensure that your solution grows
with demand
it often means sharding and scaling your
solution
ensuring that your services are set up
for high availability
and finally managing major version
upgrades and security patches
which will often incur some level of
service downtime
what if product development could be
made easier
i'd like to introduce you to cloud
firestore a purpose-built
document database service that aims to
make it easy to develop applications
firestore is the successor to cloud
datastore
it incorporates technology from the
firebase real-time database
for rapid application development
the service is available both through
google cloud and the firebase portfolio
and provides seamless integrations with
both ecosystems
so what makes firestore special
it's built to be serverless that means
it's a fully managed service that
automatically scales based on demand
and has no maintenance windows
it supports direct application to
database connections
and customizable security rules to
ensure users can only access or modify
the data that they're permitted to
access
it has built-in live data
synchronization and offline mode
making it effortless to build real-time
applications
that can withstand a network
connectivity hiccup
and finally firestore has a rich array
of supported libraries and frameworks
including those supported by google and
community maintained libraries as well
one of the key attributes of firestore
is that it's serverless
from an external developer's perspective
firestore offers a set of apis per
document
reads writes and deletes
behind the covers the service decouples
processing and storage layers
in order to automatically scale both
dimensions independently
to meet demand all data
is stored across multiple strongly
consistent replicas
in our regional offering of firestore
that means having an availability sla
of 99.99
in our multi-regional offering on
firestore that means having a service
that is resilient to whole region outage
and an availability sla of 99.999
as applications perform additional read
and write operations on the database
the database uses automated load and
range based sharding
to scale processing and storage with
minimal impact latency
in practice some customers have scaled
to tens of millions of requests per
second
and petabytes of storage
more interestingly firestore is an
elastic service that can scale resource
utilization both
up and down
as a result customers only pay for what
they use
no capacity planning is required getting
started
is also completely free with a generous
always free tier
to incubate your development
often i get the question how has spires
were used in practice
let's go through three common customer
architectures
okay let's say that you want to use
firestore for its serverless attributes
but you prefer to architecture solution
utilizing a more traditional approach
that utilizes compute services to govern
access to the database
fear or not that setup is fully
supported
in this architecture access to firestore
is authenticated and authorized
through cloud iam
since firestore is a transactional
database this architecture is often
extended to support
analytical workloads through a one-click
integration with bigquery that leverages
cloud function triggers
to stream data changes
what if you're an application
development team that wants to reduce
development time
and total cost of ownership in this
diagram you can see an architecture that
achieves
just that here mobile applications
communicate directly to the database
utilizing firestore's client libraries
authentication is handled through
firebase auth or google cloud
identity platform authorization
is managed through customizable cloud
files to firestore security rules
syncing is handled through firestore's
persistent sockets to the database
offline mode is managed through
firestore's on-device database
similar the lost architecture diagram to
support analytical workloads we
recommend customers set up a one-click
integration
with bigquery
if an application needs to present
analytical results back to the end user
customers can execute bigquery via cloud
functions
and store these results in cloud
firestore
with live synchronization the latest
results will automatically be
transmitted
to listing application connections
if you already have an existing legacy
application and database
but are facing challenges with high
availability scaling
or simply trying to build out features
for your application including real-time
collaboration in offline
mode cloud firestore is for you
we are frequently seeing customers use
cloud firestore in front of an existing
legacy database to take advantage of
these native capabilities
in this architecture cloud firestore has
been added as the primary serving
database that stands in front of a
legacy database system
to ensure that business processes can
continue to run
on the legacy database system data from
cloud firestore is often periodically
synced
using a pipeline service like cloud
dataflow
lastly it's worth mentioning that cloud
firestore is available in two modes
both modes utilize a shared processing
and storage layer
cds stored mode is fully compatible with
cloud data store
it's suitable for server to fire store
connections
native mode consists of a new document
and collections data model
it also works for server to firestore
connections
this is the mode that you want to select
if you want to enable direct application
to firestore connections
okay we've covered a lot of information
let's hear from a real customer
i would like to introduce introduce you
to marta cosarchen
who is the chief technology officer and
vice president of engineering at khan
academy
marta will be sharing how khan academy
has used firestore
to respond to a surge of demand of
online education
hello and thank you min i'll start
by sharing a little about khan academy
in our mission and then i'll talk about
how our use of the google cloud platform
including firestore
helps us to deliver on the mission in
particular today i'll talk about how
firestore along with app engine for
commute
compute enabled this to scale rapidly
in the explosion of usage of our site
beginning with shelter in place
due to the coronavirus pandemic for
those of you not familiar with khan
academy
we're an educational non-profit and our
mission is to provide a free
world-class education for anyone
anywhere
many of you will remember the origins of
khan academy as founder sal khan
described in his early ted talks
youtube videos that he made in his
walk-in closet
motivated by his success in remotely
tutoring his cousin over the internet
today we are much more than that
collection of youtube videos
today khan academy is the most effective
solution for accelerating measurable
learning
we offer free interactive instructional
learning materials and tools
for core academic subjects from
preschool through the first two years of
college
we're a supplemental resource for
teachers in the classroom
through our personalized mastery-based
offerings which focus on fluency of
foundational skills and concepts
efficacy studies show significant impact
across elementary and middle school math
and an sat prep and i'll pause for a few
seconds to let you look at these numbers
in 2019 the khan academy website served
over 94 million registered users in 190
countries
we had over 19 million monthly active
users
which we define as users who spend at
least 60 minutes
during the course of the month on the
site we served over 240 000 teachers
with content in over 40 languages
and there were over 15 billion practice
questions completed on the site
in 2020 beginning in mid-march
as schools all over the world abruptly
closed because of the pandemic
and students parents and teachers
scrambled to move to distance learning
within just two weeks khan academy site
usage grew to two and a half times what
it was at the same time last year
and we've sustained that level through
june we were able to respond to this
rapid growth
offering our high quality content and
classroom experience as usual for free
and in the month of april alone we
served 30 million learners on our
platform
a recent national survey of parents
found that khan academy was the most
used online resource i'm proud that we
absorbed this rapid growth without
disrupting our users
in addition to reacting quickly to
alleviate pressure points within a few
days
the con engineering team had prepared in
advance and that preparation paid
dividends
we scaled readily in large part because
of our architecture
and a rigorous practice of choosing
external services carefully
and using them properly
two fundamental components of our
architecture service particularly well
here serverless and caching
we use gcp including app engine
datastore and memcache
as well as other peripheral gcp services
and these three were the backbone of the
serverless and caching strategy
that's key to our scalability as you can
see in this diagram
serverless is a big lover for us using
app engine a fully managed environment
means we can scale very easily with
virtually no effort
even with a substantial traffic increase
our sites stayed up and performed well
with minimal intervention we didn't need
to worry about load balancing ourselves
because server instances were brought up
as needed
caching also plays a key role in our
scaling we use fastly cdn which allows
us to cache all static data and minimize
server trips
huge for scalability it also helps us
optimize hosting resources
we also extensively cache common queries
user preferences
and session data and we leverage this to
speed up data fetching performance
i know you want to hear about the third
workhorse in our mostly effortless
scaling
firestore firestore scales out storage
and access capacity automatically
in much the same way that app engine
scales out web server instances
we spend very little time worrying about
storage
indeed of the major parts of our system
it was the only one we didn't have to
tune at all
app engine scaling memcache and task use
did require little tuning although
minimal
it's really hard to over emphasize how
easily firestore scales without
us doing anything at all we have no need
to worry about re-sharding
or ever about adding capacity
here's a look at our june numbers to
give you a sense of the scale of our
data and site traffic even in a summer
slow month
note the 5 to 10x daily scale out of
site traffic
the auto scaling of both app engine and
firestore
helps us to minimize costs since we pay
only for what we use
i'll end by sharing a couple of the
amazing stories that our grateful users
have been sharing with us
about their experiences as the pandemic
started
here's one from a teacher i'll pause to
let you read that
and here's another from a doctor working
on the pandemic front lines
and finally i want to remind you that
we're a non-profit
thanks for having me today min back to
you
thanks marta it's exciting to see khan
academy's broad impact
at an acute time of need the cloud
firestore team is humbled to help
customers like you
make that possible next i'd like to
share
some product announcements
we wrapped up 2019 with a class of
features to support
richer queries on firestar
this includes collection groups along
with in an array contains any queries
we also added support for increment and
decrement operations
more recently we made it easy for unity
and c plus developers to adopt firestore
it's also now simple to programmatically
create
firestore databases using terraform
and you can create those databases in
four new locations
bringing our total global footprint to
19 locations
around the world
moving forward a major theme of
investment for firestar
includes metrics and performance
optimization tools
to support this we've launched usage
dashboards
and apis to improve throughput of both
bulk rights and read operations
one of the more exciting features that
is coming soon is a new performance
profiler for cloud firestore
called key visualizer
and with that i want to hand it over to
arash we'll be digging a bit deeper
into key visualizer
thank you amin hi my name is arash parsa
and i'm a software engineer here at
cloud firestore
i'll be talking about firestore key
visualizer which is an exciting new
feature we will be launching the alpha
soon
cloud firestore is built for automatic
scaling and high performance
out of the box still sometimes when we
talk to our customers
we hear a statement such as i'm
experiencing media latency of
hundreds of milliseconds for my lookup
operations is that expected
or i'm experiencing p99 latency of order
of a few seconds for my right operations
is that normal and often the answer is
no
we commonly find these performance
problems to be due to
the incoming traffic violating the
service best practices
let's use an example to explore one of
the ways an implementation might
violate these best practices i'm a new
cloud firestore customer
and i'm working on launching a new api
in this api i would simply
receive documents and store them in my
firestore database
in this case i've implemented a function
that generates the document ids for me
and this function generates these
document ids incrementally
it's worth noting that we also find
these incremental id patterns
often when customers are importing data
from other databases such as mysql
where auto incrementing ids are common
let's see what kind of traffic pattern
this implementation will result too
as you can see in this picture this will
result with sequential write pattern in
my key space
keys are the full paths to your
documents
so for any given document the key is
going to
include all the parent collections in
addition to the document id which is the
last part of the key
firestore is a wrench ordered service at
any point in time
your key space is going to map to a
number of underlying shards
the undesired property of this right
pattern is that at any point in time
your load is focused on a single
underlying shard
cloud firestore supports sequential
loads at
up to 500 requests per second at higher
levels of load this can result in
hottest spot
and for example it can show itself in
your api in the form of elevated
latencies or
errors cloud firestore automatic scaling
capabilities enables you to scale up
your load
to millions millions of requests per
second
more specifically by following our ramp
up guideline which suggests to generally
increase your load by fifty percent
every five minutes you can scale up your
row
your load to tens of millions of
requests per second
and still in a random service a
sequential load pattern continues to map
to a single chart
and hence can result in hot spots
at cloud firestore we are constantly
working to provide you with better
features that can
help you diagnose this type of
performance problems we are excited to
launch key visualizer
in alpha soon this tool provides you
with visibility
into the traffic patterns of your
database across the key
space and helps you self-diagnose a
number of different performance problems
let's go back to the customer story that
we were just reviewing
so in preparation for my api launch i've
set up load tests that can hopefully
represent that
the traffic that i'm going to receive
during after my launch
during this load test i start to observe
that i'm experiencing
some poor performance for my write
operations
i jump to the key visualizer view in
order to start the debugging process
and get an understanding of where the
root cause of the problem might be
cloud firestore key visualizer provides
two dimensional heat maps
of your project's traffic
in this heat map views the horizontal
axis is
time increasing from left to right
and the vertical axis is your key space
with the lower key values located at the
bottom
and your largest keys located at the top
firestore key visualizer heat map views
are two hours wide
the heated scale at the top left
provides the color coding that is used
in this heat map
in particular i can see that black or
dark purple
indicates that the metric value is one
of the lower values
versus the glowing white which indicates
those regions are carrying some of the
higher values for this metric
fire circuit visualizer provides a
number of different metrics
including your total qps
in addition to the qps broken down for
your write
lookup and query operations
it also includes latency metrics for
these three rpc categories
going back to the example that we were
just reviewing i start by examining the
right
latencies metric using the provided
color coding here
i can identify that there is a
sequential load pattern
that is accompanied with elevated levels
of latency
in particular i can find regions
where the average latency can go as high
as a few seconds
this is certainly not good and indicates
that there is a serious performance
degradation happening
next i switch to the right qps metric
using this metric i can observe that
this sequential load pattern
is operating at higher than 5000
requests per second
thinking back about cloud files for best
practices
i recall that sequential load patterns
are well supported up to 500 requests
per second
but otherwise at higher levels of load
they can result in
hot spots and performance problems
i can confirm with my application code
that the document ids within this
collection
are in fact being set sequentially and
this is the likely source and root cause
of this performance problem
in this case i will go ahead and change
my implementation
to use the firestore auto-generated ids
which are randomized by default
and redeploy my code to production
next i can use key visualizer to confirm
that my
traffic is now well distributed across
my key space
and that my latencies have moved back to
the normal range
okay great i was able to use key
visualizer
to efficiently debug and resolve a
performance issue
now there are a number of other use
cases that you can actually use key
visualizer for for performance debugging
for instance in this case as a customer
i'm able to quickly identify that
collection fuel is the one that is
having performance issues
even though my right operations look to
be pretty well distributed in this case
it seems like there is there is another
reason that my rights are performing
poorly
i start by examining the documents which
are being written in this collection
and identify that these documents are
carrying a field
that contains the time of insertion of
the dock
cloud firestore indexes are strongly
consistent
and hence they are updated at the time
of your document rights
this means that if you're doing if
you're performing rights
with documents that have sequential feed
values those can also result in hot
spots
on your indexes in the case that you
have documents with sequential field
values
you should either exempt them from
indexing in the case that you don't need
them for your queries
or in the case that you need them for
your queries you can partition
those heavy write patterns for instance
by applying a random prefix
to those sequential field values in the
case that
you use this technique you would need to
re-aggregate the result
on the read side okay so we reviewed a
couple of examples where you might
experience performance problems
due to violating the best practices
please continue to review
our full list of best practices in order
to make sure you're fully utilizing the
all the high performance capabilities
that are built into cloud firestore and
now i'm going to hand it over to min
to take us home thank you arash
and thank you to all the viewers who
joined us today this concludes our
session
if you haven't signed up for cloud
firestore we hope you take the
opportunity
to get started for free if you have
questions about today's presentation
please feel free to post your questions
on the dory if you'd like to learn more
about how
customers are using cloud firestore i
encourage you to join the new york times
session
which will discuss how they utilize
cloud firestore to power collaborative
editing
and finally we encourage you to join our
large community of developers on stack
overflow
thank you